[Music]
i'm a pack rat
and i come from a long line of pack
rattery
and i would say it goes back
you know at least three generations as
many generations as i have ever known
probably more
so
the last few years my wife and i
have been able to
take the steps and really
get the ball rolling on simplifying our
own lives
but now i really worry about my parents
because
in the past few years
a few of my grandparents have passed
away and moved on
and my parents
just because of the situation they are
going to have to
deal
with everything not just
their own things but my grandparents
things as well this includes
houses
garages
storage sheds and even an entire ranch
just filled with clutter
so it's an overwhelming task and i
you know i've tried to to help out where
i can um
but at this point it's
i don't know that it's really welcome
and
so on top of it being frustrating it's
it's a very emotional experience because
not only are my parents dealing
with their own possessions that they've
acquired but now
they have to deal with
basically
you know
several lifetimes coming together
so my one remaining grandmother
she
she's dealing with alzheimer's and
um so she's been living
and
my parents have decided that it would be
best for her to finish out her time here
if they were all to move back to her
house and so they're going to be
combining those two households which
already they're carrying a lot of things
so
one of you said
you mentioned that
sometimes it's our job to brainwash our
kids
and i was wondering if you had any
thoughts or tips on
possibly brainwashing our parents
or others um
you know that just mean that much to us
[Laughter]
i don't remember saying brainwashing
this sounds like something ryan would
say jokingly ingest yeah right he
doesn't actually mean to brainwash your
kids and i know i can tell from the
spirit of brandon's question you're
approaching this in a way
that it's a really difficult subject and
so you're bringing some levity into it
brandon i really appreciate that because
it's overwhelming and before we started
recording this we're doing a live stream
with our patrons here shout out to the
live stream leave your uh comments or
questions in the chat we'll get to them
as soon as we can but podcast sean was
talking about
when his grandmother died in 2013
he realized that he was burdened by a
lot of her stuff she didn't realize he
was going to be burdened by in fact she
was holding on to a lot of these things
clinging to these things so that shawn
and his family and his extended family
would have access to them not knowing
that he might be burdened by them but
sean what was the outcome
when you finally had to start dealing
with her stuff what did you realize
well
i should clarify too it was actually
2014 when she passed but my father
passed in 2013. so it's like back to
back and my dad and her
um
kind of like you i mean had
were highly organized this was really
clean they were clean fastidiously clean
people
just did a really good job at hiding
just how much stuff they had
and packing this stuff away
and so yeah that's the thing we did not
really realize with my grandmother
because she was by herself at this point
when she passed
and when we went in there and started
cleaning that house out and getting it
prepped you know to to sell
all i could think to myself and this is
before we really worked together as you
know as part of the minimalist team that
wasn't until you know late 2014 early
2015
um but i kept thinking to myself as i'm
going through and finding another thing
and another thing and another thing and
just deeper and deeper right and things
that are obviously brand new that she
completely forgot about
i thought oh man this is so
much
work
i don't want to do this to my kids
i don't want to do this to any of my
survivors i don't want them to go
through my stuff and be the same way
right but just feeling that burden and
putting that burden on someone else and
they don't i i'm sure she wasn't
thinking that right i mean she came from
a generation of growing up in the
depression and they were thinking oh i
better say this i'm probably gonna need
it later yeah or somebody's gonna need
it later 100
yeah but well it's interesting because
sean came to that conclusion himself
through experiencing going through his
his relatives uh who have passed like
going through their things
and that is that's the only
brainwashing i'm joking and doing air
quotes that's going to be very clear
right now to who people who aren't
watching this
we're actually going to have on the
maximum episode this week we're going to
have someone who is accusing us of being
very cult-like so oh yeah that would be
fun i yeah i uh
we i think we are a little cultish after
talking to amanda montal i mean we all
belong to some sort of cult anyway
um yeah so
so yeah uh yeah i get it brainwashing
comes along with uh with being in a cult
um but but look sean brainwashed himself
essentially that's what happened yes and
you know for us to sit here and be like
well here's how here's how you can
manipulate your relatives
into getting rid of their stuff like
that
josh and i are not um
we're not encouraging you to manipulate
we're not encouraging you to brainwash
the only thing that josh and i really
are encouraging people to do in this
situation like this is is to be
supportive and that's the only way you
can really get through
uh to anyone in this type of situation
it's
how can you help them
and and when they ask for help then be
at the ready to help them uh i mean i
i've got relatives who and and you know
mariah has relatives who are
uh who hold on to stuff and like i don't
go to their house and judge them
um i don't try to brainwash them um some
of them have asked for help and then
i'll give them some ideas and and try to
help them out but but there is no
brainwashing in this the the no one
likes to be manipulated
so um so yeah it's this is more of a
matter of how can you support your
relatives how can you be compassionate
towards your relatives and then it's not
even nudging them it's more about just
being there when they are asked for help
like be they're ready to help them i
agree that we don't want to brainwash
anyone right however i understand where
he's coming from i
need to convey this so i'm not burdened
by this stuff and so
instead of convincing them
that they have too much stuff because
convincing doesn't work either a man
convinced against his will is of the
same opinion still and that
certainly goes for your parents
what i'll say here is
you can help them understand
right now they don't understand that
this stuff
is a burden or if they do
they don't understand the gravity of
that burden they might realize like oh
yeah it's a little bit of stuff they'll
have to sort through it but it's better
for the whole family if we hold on to
these things that's the story they're
telling themselves but if you ask them
some very pointed compassionate kind
questions i feel for you and where you
are right now brandon because you don't
want to be burdened by these things and
so i wouldn't go to it in a way that's
saying no no no
i would go to in a way that helps them
understand that if they hold on to too
many things what they're doing is
weighing your future self down so let's
talk practically what you can do you can
tell them hey there are some things that
you own right now that i would love to
inherit that's how you say yes
to them holding on to some stuff so
don't just hop in there and this goes to
ruth and her question earlier as well
you don't want to just hop in there and
say no no no you walk out of the house
you look at all the stuff no to that no
to that no no no no no no no no no i
don't want your stuff
okay
that's not helpful but what if you go to
the house say oh wow look at these 12
things i would really like to hold on to
that and that and that
hey what about this dresser no i don't i
have a use for that personally but
someone else might find value in it
let's see if anyone else in the family
is interested in that i was talking to
my wife about this just yesterday
i said when your parents pass away you
know thankfully they're really healthy
and they'll be here for a long time
but
eventually they'll we all die and there
will be some stuff
how is your family going to handle that
are they going to feel compelled to give
it all to you and she said no i think
some of my family will find value in
many of those things but we're not going
to fight over those things
but we're also not going to force other
people to take the things that we don't
want yeah and i thought that was a
really mature perspective here because
really when we're talking about
inheriting there are some things we want
to inherit sure but most of the things
we have no desire
to be burdened by in the first place so
you can set that expectation right now
by saying yes to the things you know you
want and allowing them to pass on the
other things that someone else will get
value from because just because you're
not going to get value from the thing
doesn't mean that someone else won't get
value from it and they might even get
value from it now so letting go of it
right now
or this year or soon will mean it's not
taking up space not collecting dust
not being treated like a dead thing in a
mausoleum
it can have a new life in someone else's
house and how freeing is that
yeah i just want to pipe in real quick
because this reminded me as you were
talking about this um when i was in grad
school for education i took an ed site
course
and an ed psych one of the things they
say is you don't want to tell students
this is how we learn as humans
don't tell students what you don't want
them to do
emphasize what you want them to do
emphasize the positive behavior
incentivize don't punish did you enjoy
this standalone patreon highlight if so
you can listen to full episodes of the
minimalist private podcast available
exclusively on patreon visit patreon.com
the minimalists or click the link in the
description your support keeps our
podcast and youtube channel 100 percent
advertisement free